[Musique]
alors on vous dire actuellement c'est
vrai quel jour on a tout dit avec vous
aujourd'hui elle vit dans un petit hôtel
c'est ça peut pas tout le temps même le
payer elle vit dans sa voiture dans les
quartiers de paris
elle a un peu de travail et là peu tout
ça et puis dernièrement on a appris
aussi que l est recherché par la police
parce qu'elle serait en danger de mort
regardez le sujet et puis derrière on en
parle
alors que depuis quelques années ophélie
winter s'était faite discrète elle est
de retour cette semaine sur le devant de
la scène mais pour des raisons qui sont
loin d'être artistique
si la reine des années 90 et 2000 avait
l'habitude d'enflammer les dancefloors
c'est aujourd'hui dans la rubrique faits
divers que la star signe un retour
médiatique assez triste en effet le
magazine public à retrouver ophélie et
ça ne va pas fort la jeune femme qui
était mariée à un riche entrepreneur
hollandais qui vivait à dubaï depuis
plusieurs années a divorcé et s'est
retrouvé sans rien retour à la case
départ en mai dernier dans son petit
appartement de neuilly mais au fil des
mois les choses se sont empirées elle a
quitté son appartement et la descente
aux enfers s'est poursuivie jusqu'à la
semaine dernière où la jeune femme a été
prise en photo à la sortie d'un hôtel
très modestes dans lequel elle aurait
passé plusieurs nuits certains passants
prétendent même avoir vu la star dormir
dans sa voiture des photos tristes qui
ont beaucoup choqué cette semaine dans
tpm paix au fil des winter s'est
expliqué sur cette situation mais il ne
l'est pas du tout alors une question se
pose maintenant fallait-il dévoiler ses
photos d'ophélie winter voilà qu'on
apprend cette semaine on a changé par
myriam qui est là et puis sébastien qui
a beaucoup beaucoup suit lé dos et c'est
normal vous n'êtes pas paradis pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui elle serait elle
serait au conditionnel a recherché par
la police il estimerait qu'elle est en
danger de mort
des menaces sérieuses poserait sur sa
sécurité
mais pourquoi une crevasse à sa vie ben
ali a certainement quelqu'un qui lui en
veut pour une raison imagine mais
pourquoi je n'ai pas oui toi que vous
avez vous pouvez pas en parler non non
je n'ai pas juge pas sûr donc je vais
pas affirmer les choses dont je suis pas
sûr j'entends dans tous les cas c'est
vrai qu'il ya un réel danger et il
voudrait la placer sous protection très
bien il ya il c'est quoi cette histoire
avec son son ex petite amie qui était
donc elle vivait à dubaï c'est ça il ya
encore peu de temps il ya combien de
temps il y a encore quelques semaines je
pense et c'est le retour précipité dubaï
et c'est ce retour précipité qui
explique peut-être qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose là-bas qui a déplu à son
ex compagnon on a dit encore mieux
renseigné que la police est là on peut
mettre des conditionnels retrouver
ophélie winter plus vite que la police
met donc non mais je pense que c'est pas
c'est pas évident non plus pour la
police de retrouver quelqu'un qui est
quelque part dans pareil moment on m'a
dit pas pardon jeudi un petit peu tout
mais on m'a dit que quand on l'a eu au
téléphone notre jour dans tpm piccirilli
au téléphone comme elle devait venir
dans l'émission finalement elle a annulé
sa venue s'est elle est née dernier la
police s'était presque refait s'était
rendu dans les locaux de 2,2 lakanal
factory fils y pensant pouvoir trouver
ophélie winter dire que la police en
france
enfin vous vous avez trouvé la politique
et paparazzi en deux semaines en
cherchant et la police sait pas où elle
est elle dans les rues de paris l'a
trouvée par les mêmes réseaux
d'information on a des informateurs et
des raisons des informations qui seront
plus adaptés pour retrouver des
personnalités qui ont eu en général
cherche plutôt des centraux pour dire
parce que voilà vous y était
conditionnel mais vous pensez qu'il ya
un lien entre le fait qu'elle soit
menacée de mort aujourd'hui et sa
séparation à dubaï c'est probable mais
je ne suis sûr de rien très bien on va
ouvrir un petit peu élargir aussi un
petit peu le dossier myriam est ce que
quand on voit aujourd'hui je vous dis la
vérité on a vu beaucoup de photos d'elle
voilà on va dire la vérité ça va elle va
elle va très très mal aujourd'hui c'est
très difficile de lui parler de lui
tendre la main
même ses parents je crois on parlait pas
très longtemps l'udc qu'est ce que
quelqu'un dit sa mère et qu'est ce
qu'elle dit son frère à ce qu'ils ont
découvert la situation sestak quand nous
à causeur on a contacté plus ou moins
assure l'arrière nahles jusque là sa
mère a découvert par public justement
que sa fille était rentrée que sa fille
allait si mal parce que sa fille lui
répond plus depuis le mois d'avril où
une grosse dispute entre elles pour une
histoire de placement d'argent pas très
important finalement elles se parlent
plus et la mère ne savait pas que vous
cofely été dans cette situation là
qu'elle avait plus on à part qu'elle
n'avait pas d'argent et la mère est pas
calquer lui dit mais tu chine essaie de
l'appeler c'est de la joindre le frère
aussi elle ne leur répond pas parce
qu'elle veut se débrouiller tout seul et
c'est une famille qui peut l'aider face
à un accord à quelqu'un de balle est
allée en place quoi s'ils voulaient ni
par son frère n'est pas raison mais en
fait non comme elle dit comme l a dit
dans un pea facile quant à la 10e je
vais tout seul je veux faire rappeler
personne c'est vrai sur personne elle
est dans une espèce de bulle de
désapprouver com
harry le frère ça passe avoue que ça
fait quand même des semaines voire des
mois peut-être des années que ses
parents savent pas du tout du tout les
tweets ne vient qu'à la coopec sa mère
donc ses récents qu'elle répare mais du
coup elle cette descente aux enfers sa
balle est toujours à dubaï mireille
quand on voit la descente aux enfers là
parce que pareil on appelait photos qui
sont un public là vous avez été très
gentil même si les photos sont horribles
la réalité bien pire de ce qu'on a vu
mais faux pas est ce que vous vous
culpabilisez un peu d'avoir sorti cette
histoire de montrer ces photos là
certains disent 'peut-être que ces
photos ça va être le coût final et quand
elle va le voir ça elle peut tomber en
dépression alors que déjà elle va très
mal est-ce que ça peut pas la faire même
basculé dans quelque chose qui serait
horrible et évidemment du dieu merci
j'espère ça n'arrivera jamais enfin
voila vous prenez des risques en jouant
avec des gens qui vont si mal
effectivement quand je quand on est
sorti toutes ces infos déjà on s'est
posé la question est-ce qu'on utilise le
mot sdf c'est hyper violent on savait
forcément à la lettre voir ça dans
l'équipe donc on sait qu on y a beaucoup
réfléchi comment pouvait tourner les
choses pour qu'elles ne soient pas
blessés
et quand on a fait la deuxième couvent
pour expliqué qu'effectivement elle
était recherché par la police pour des
causes très grave qui visiblement se
sont passées à dubai vous n'avez plus
bien sûr que j'en sais plus il ya des
choses qu'on peut pas dire c'est pas
forcément là on parle beaucoup on a
beaucoup parlé de son ex hollandais mais
c'est pas forcément avec cet ex là que
ça s'est passé c'est cco à dubai on peut
pas faire tout ce qu'on veut et à dubaï
quand vous allez à dubai c'est une super
vilains tout le monde y va etc
il ya des choses qu'on peut se permettre
quoique on peut avoir une idée sur ce
que ça nul des doigts on vous parlait on
a pris le parti de ne pas mais je sais
ce que c'est autre chose
est ce que c'est de l'ordre de criminels
est ce que c'était désigne arabes unis
qui sont pas les mêmes mais quelle règle
ou alors il ya la drogue
il ya aussi l'aide de tromper de tromper
de tromper quelqu'un ils font que toutes
ces choses peuvent vous mettre effet
temps d'accord et du coup nous quand on
a fait sept coups déjà on voulait pas on
s'est beaucoup reposé la question est ce
que le fait de le dire et puis je vais
vous dire honnêtement ce qui s'est passé
c'est que moi je n'ai pas dormi de la
nuit
quand j'ai fait cette couv et j'en ai
parlé beaucoup à mon mari et mon mari
qui est plutôt du genre à me calmer
parce que moi je suis dans le truc et
voilà il m'a dit je pense que ça peut
lui rendre service et j'espère vraiment
que ça va le rendre service
opposé à tout ce côté aussi si par
hasard je dis bien si par hasard et je
souhaite surtout que ce soit que ce que
ça allait beaucoup mieux qu'on va lui
tendent les mains qu'avec les accepter
si par hasard ça allait mal et qu au
contraire ça a pu encore plus sa déprime
et qu'on bascule dans l'horreur
est ce que vous vous sentiriez oui
coupable auquel cas responsable et je me
suis dit je suis désolée je dirais même
le contraire je trouve que d'avoir
alerté et la population et sa famille et
les flics quelque part et les hôpitaux
et le samu qui on veut que d'avoir
alerté sur ce feu dans quel état elle va
c'est plutôt une chance pourrait que
quelqu'un l'aide va sortir la ramène en
cure fasse quelque chose pour eux enfin
voilà s'en occupe que si elle était
restée dans la déchéance dans les rues
de paris et quels gens comme ça qui les
titres et vous en parlais tout à l'heure
les titres sdf ruine et n'amène rien ce
n'est pas évident non mais ses proches
et les amis et tous ne pourront pas dire
on ne savait pas donc voilà maintenant
vous quelqu'un lui tendre la main
ouais la police si elle n'arrive pas à
la retrouver un peu toujours s'adresser
à des gens qui s'est passé mais pas non
plus leur spécialité donc voilà donc
maintenant tout a été mis en alerte pour
que les gens qui doivent l'aider le
fasse je pensais mais je ne culpabilise
et la presse people moi je trouve cela
odieux
enfin c'est quand même pas la presse
people camille ophélie winter la pauvre
dans l'état où le jeune anton va très
très mal on n'a pas forcément envie dans
ses dérives mais rien nous arriver dès
juin et elle ne dit pas tout en quoi la
presse people serait jamais vous sent un
mag et d'ipad gens s'en seraient
responsables ce qui pour albert legatt
la tuque n'est pas responsable
pas beaucoup de temps je vais vous savez
pour sortir d'un problème il faut
admettre qu'il y a un problème et le
souci c'est que fait les winter ne va
pas mal depuis quelques mois elle va mal
depuis 15 ans et on le sait dans ce
métier moi je travaille en maison disque
on savait donc c'est pas nouveau et ça
fait quinze ans qu'elle dit non tout va
bien il ya aucun souci elle a encore dit
par téléphone la semaine dernière mais
c'est son droit
maintenant c'est je pense qu'à partir du
26 en drainant on peut pas dire poser
bien aussi moi personnellement ça me
choque
la raison c'est qu'on dit sur sa
filiation c'est 50% de la guérison
ah oui voilà on s'est fixé vous avez
fait boire pour reconnaître on sait que
l'on parle du haut mais on sait aussi
qu'il a des soucis qu'il faut qu'il
faudrait vraiment réussira à soigner ça
ça changerait tout regardez le sondage
justement fait il des volets ou pas les
photos de philippe winter non à 70 %
voilà je dis la vérité je suis très
partagé je sais pas j'ai juste très peur
d'un très peur de l'avenir dont je
souhaite beaucoup beaucoup de bonnes
choses